[Music]
this is it the car we've all been
waiting for the new Tesla Model X
combines the space and height of a major
SUV the electric power of the Model S
sedan and the luxury expected from a
hundred thousand dollar vehicle this
week we're at the Los Angeles Auto Show
but the Model X isn't actually even at
the show tesla gave us a sneak peek with
the car and from the limited time I had
with it I can honestly say I did not
find a thing to complain about I don't
know the visibility is the first thing I
noticed this thing is just big dirt he's
like there are no walls at all I mean
the windshield it's behind your head the
visibility is amazing it monitors the
car in front of you you can see that car
pulling away that's so cool I love it I
don't want to gush too much about this
long-awaited machine but it's pretty
close to everything we've hoped for the
whole thing is covered in supple leather
with seat heaters controlled by the
center computer screen and wow that's
green this thing is packed with a 259
horsepower electric motor that powers
the front wheels and a 503 horsepower
motor that powers the rear the Model X
has a 250 mile range and can hit 60
miles per hour in 3.8 seconds it has a
top speed of 155 miles per hour now
that's a lot of numbers but ensure the
message is this the new Model X is
phenomenal place your order now because
it's going to go fast